thanks for we are here with a big Victor
of today's round that is Fabiano caruana
who took down mvl Fabi first of all a
big surprise in the opening you started
off with D4 we've seen those Tendencies
from you but then at move three you play
this move H4 tell us a bit about that
yeah well I
am a few years behind the times I think
because H4 got really popular again it's
like an kind of invention of grishuk
like so many opinion ideas these days
and it got really really popular and
Maximus faced it many times and I
actually wasn't surprised that he
decided to go for the benko against it
because
um I don't know if you remember his his
game with the white pieces against Peter
squiddler
it reached this position and Maxine
himself against Peter played uh played
this
and they kind of reached
they they reached
a game which Maxine kind of won very
very brilliantly
uh 98 or K1 King f8
and uh I think like simply like H5 here
and he won a brilliant game but at some
point the engine in that game I think
was giving black decent chances yeah it
was it was a four-star if black was
playing it correctly and so I wasn't too
surprised I kind of knew that you can
also play like this it's basically a
Banco Gambit where white for absolutely
no reason for the pawn in H4 so it's
like it's the best benko you could have
but uh but it is
this move I didn't know okay it looked
very natural to do this but yeah I only
played rookie one when I saw this bishop
G5
because if I play E5 then tag Rook takes
Rook fd8 I thought it's very unclear yes
but Bishop G5 is strong I thought he
would go for this position here
I thought if he takes with the bishop
unfortunately I have this very strong
rookie for
queen of five and queen E2 and I think
he just gets crushed basically because I
collected yeah
whatever I want so he he should probably
play ef6 yeah and I thought like I can
play Rook C1 here he's not and if I get
b39 B5 then I have a good position
um I know sorry no Knight B5 first yeah
because I forced Rook fd8 probably and
now I was thinking okay Rook C1 but I
wasn't sure about F5 here Rook C4 fe4
Rook here Queen F5 I thought it's super
dangerous for black but
still this is something a long way to
win to win the game very good
calculation so
so then he surprised me I didn't think
this move was possible
but it took me a long time to calculate
this G3 and Knight bd3 because it still
looks pretty scary right kind of like I
think wins for black if not for Knight
G5 yeah or at least very dangerous but I
saw this move and I was trying to figure
out these complications I was a bit
confused but I think Maxim said after
the game the bishop takes a fate and
then Knight B5 is a very important move
and uh Knight D3 Maybe
just from three three yeah it's it's
complex but it kind of doesn't work but
I thought he should probably go for it
because it's a difficult Choice here
which work to take with
um this at first I didn't even
understand his point and then I
understood that that this is actually
getting a little bit unclear
it looks like dead lost I mean
by all means it is except that he has
this Knight C3 and I wasn't sure I
thought like
I thought this might be kind of Winnie
but then I saw this 92 move and I got a
bit scared but I see the computers as
king H2 so but okay I was I was thinking
that this this could be winning 94 and
some move like it looked like something
here should be winning five seems yeah
but then I thought okay why why not at
this is Queen D3 I mean
um
there was one moment even after this
move F5 which I think from a practical
perspective was definitely
um the right choice if it goes to D4
what was your plan at this point okay so
first I was going to repeat once yeah
and then I was going to think about the
earlier position so the point is like
Rook D1 looks very very strong but this
this end game
I wasn't sure I thought it's probably
winning like okay I can go for this it's
kind of safe yeah but all my pawns are
weak so you can see drawing chances here
if things go wrong so I was going to
either go for this
um or okay at first I'll repeat and here
I saw a move which looked really
tempting which was the move um
Queen D1 I think
and for Rook D3 so I thought Knight D3
Queen D3
um FG then I probably even have like 94
stuff
um yeah so so I thought he takes FG
first and I was going to like calculate
this position but I didn't see how he
probably doesn't have enough composition
yeah I mean it's a piece and he's not
talking about so many pieces so uh but I
thought I might as well include throw
this in because okay Queen Street is
clearly just like you no longer have
threats right I think he was counting on
this suddenly oh um not this Rook d one
that was um or G1 Knight of two one
maybe Knight F3 oh this is terrible for
uh but Bishop C5 looks super super
um winning but then I saw that he has
some move here like Bishop takes E5 I'm
sorry uh Rook takes E5 and D6 King h8
rookie five Bishop B5 I mean it must be
completely winning but I started to get
a bit confused because Bishop before
this bishop G3 and okay obviously I
should so I started to get a little bit
worried here but
I mean it's not even spotted it just
really really kills him very nice uh
game with the white piece is quite an
encouraging sign for your tournament
starting off uh with Blast how do you
feel about the event so far how do you
feel about your shape up to this point
yeah I missed something big in the first
game but today I feel like I calculated
well and
to be fair I think Maxine wasn't was
playing far from his best today I mean
he he really didn't um
like he missed Bishop takes E7 he said
so this is a sign that he was really not
in good form today but I did what I had
to do so overall it's good Bobby
definitely took advantage of your
opportunities in this one
congratulations we'll see you in the
next few games thanks
thank you Christian if you could ask
Fabi did he when was the last time he
won and just two dozen moves uh winning
out of the opening is rare especially in
the 2800 clubs
so what Yasser is asking is when is the
last time that you can remember when you
won more or less out of the opening
and a classical business because Robin
Blitz probably happens quite often
um in a classical game let me think I
think against uh gookash and Vikings it
wasn't like out of the opening but I got
a really really huge Advantage more or
less if I move 15 and I more or less
always kept the advantage it wasn't like
this where it was like let's say plus
four but it was kind of plus two and and
stayed around there yeah but it's so
difficult yeah that was still like a
long game went more or less to the end
game so it was something like this it
has been quite a long time
there you have it yeah
rare indeed to win our congratulations
Bobby as he pulls himself uh